intelligence what is it if we take a
look back at the history of how
intelligence has been viewed one seminal
example has been Edsger Dijkstra's
famous quote that the question of
whether a machine can think is about as
interesting as the question of whether a
submarine can swim now Edsger Dijkstra
when he wrote this intended it as a
criticism of the early pioneers of
computer science like Alan Turing
however if you take a look back and
think about what have been the most
empowering innovations that enabled us
to build artificial machines that swim
and artificial machines that think you
find that it was only through
understanding the underlying physical
mechanisms of swimming and flight that
we were able to build these machines and
so several years ago I undertook a
program to try to understand the
fundamental physical mechanisms
underlying intelligence let's take a
step back let's first begin with a
thought experiment pretends that you're
an alien race that doesn't know anything
about earth biology or earth
neuroscience or earth intelligence but
you have amazing telescopes and you're
able to watch the earth and you have
amazingly long lives so you're able to
watch the earth over millions even
billions of years and you observe a
really strange effect you observe that
over the course of the millenia earth is
continually bombarded with asteroids up
until a point and that at some point
corresponding roughly to our year 2000
ad asteroids that are on a collision
course with the earth that otherwise
would have collided mysteriously get
deflected or they detonate before they
can hit the earth
now of course as Earthlings we know the
reason would be that we're trying to
save ourselves we're trying to prevent
an impact but if you're an alien race
doesn't know any of this doesn't have
any concept of Earth intelligence you'd
be forced to put together a physical
theory that explains how up until a
certain point in time asteroids that
would demolish the surface of a planet
mysteriously stop doing that and so I
claim that this is the same question as
understanding the physical nature of
intelligence
so in this program that I undertook
several years ago I looked at a variety
of different threads across science
across a variety of disciplines that
were pointing I think towards a single
underlying mechanism for intelligence in
cosmology for example there have been a
variety of different threads of evidence
that our universe appears to be finely
tuned for the development of
intelligence and in particular for the
development of Universal states that
maximize the diversity of possible
futures in gameplay for example in go
everyone remembers in 1997 when IBM's
deep blue beat Garry Kasparov at chess
fewer people are aware that in the past
ten years or so the game of Go arguably
a much more challenging game because it
has a much higher branching factor has
also started to succumb to computer game
players for the same reason the best
techniques right now for computers
playing go are techniques that try to
maximize future options during gameplay
finally in robotic motion planning there
have been a variety of recent techniques
that have tried to take advantage of
abilities of robots to maximize future
freedom of action in order to accomplish
complex tasks and so taking all of these
different threads and putting them
together
I asked starting several years ago is
there an underlying mechanism for
intelligence that we can factor out of
all of these different threads is there
a single
equation for intelligence and the answer
I believe is yes what you're seeing is
probably the closest equivalent to an e
equals mc-squared
for intelligence that I've seen so what
you're seeing here is a statement of
Correspondence that intelligence is a
force F that acts so as to maximize
future freedom of action it acts to
maximize future freedom of action or
keep options open with some strength T
with the diversity of possible
accessible futures s up to some future
time horizon tau in short intelligence
doesn't like to get trapped intelligence
tries to maximize future freedom of
action and keep options open and so
given this one equation it's natural to
ask so what can you do with this how
predictive is it does it predict human
level intelligence does it predict
artificial intelligence so I'm going to
show you now a video that will I think
demonstrate some of the amazing
applications of just this single
equation recent research in cosmology
has suggested that universes that
produce more disorder or entropy over
their lifetimes should tend to have more
favorable conditions for the existence
of intelligent beings such as ourselves
but what if that tentative cosmological
connection between entropy and
intelligence hints at a deeper
relationship
what if intelligent behavior doesn't
just correlate with the production of
long term entropy but actually emerges
directly from it to find out we
developed a software engine called
entropica designed to maximize the
production of long term entropy of any
system that it finds itself in amazingly
entropica was able to pass multiple
animal intelligence tests play human
games and even earn money trading stocks
all without being instructed to do so
here are some examples of entropica in
action just like a human standing
upright without falling over here we see
in tropica automatically balancing a
pole using a cart
this behavior is remarkable in part
because we never gave in tropica a goal
it simply decided on its own to balance
the
poll this balancing ability will have
applications for humanoid robotics and
human assistive technologies
just as some animals can use objects in
their environments as tools to reach
into narrow spaces here we see that in
tropica again on its own initiative was
able to move a large disk representing
an animal around so as to cause a small
disk representing a tool to reach into a
confined space holding a third disc and
release the third disc from its
initially fixed position this tool
usability will have applications for
smart manufacturing and agriculture in
addition just as some other animals are
able to cooperate by pulling opposite
ends of a rope at the same time to
release food here we see that in tropica
is able to accomplish a model version of
that task this cooperative ability has
interesting implications for economic
planning and a variety of other fields
entropica is broadly applicable to a
variety of domains for example here we
see it successfully playing a game of
pong against itself illustrating its
potential for gaming here we see in
tropica orchestrating new connections on
a social network where friends are
constantly falling out of touch and
successfully keeping the network well
connected this same Network
orchestration ability also has
applications in health care energy and
intelligence here we see in tropica
directing the paths of a fleet of ships
successfully discovering and utilizing
the Panama Canal to globally extend its
reach from the Atlantic to the Pacific
by the same token entropica is broadly
applicable to problems in autonomous
defense logistics and transportation
finally here we see entropica
spontaneously discovering and executing
a buy low sell high strategy on a
simulated range traded stock
successfully growing assets under
management exponentially this risk
management ability will have broad
applications in finance and insurance so
what you've just seen is that a variety
of signature human intelligent cognitive
behaviors such as tool use and walking
upright and social cooperation all
follow from a single equation
which drives a system to maximize its
future freedom of action now there's a
profound irony here going back to the
beginning of the usage of the term robot
the play were are you are there was
always a concept that if we developed
machine intelligence there would be a
cybernetic revolt the machines would
rise up against us
one major consequence of this work is
that maybe all of these decades we've
had the whole concept of cybernetic
revolt in Reverse it's not that machines
first become intelligent and then
megalomaniacal and try to take over the
world
it's quite the opposite that the urge to
take control of all possible futures is
a more fundamental principle than that
of intelligence that general
intelligence may in fact emerge directly
from this sort of control grabbing
rather than vice-versa
another important consequence is goal
seeking I'm often asked how does the
ability to seek goals follow from this
sort of framework and the answer is the
ability to seek goals will follow
directly from this in the following
sense just like you would travel through
a tunnel a bottleneck in your future
path space in order to achieve many
other diverse objectives later on or
just like you would invest in a
financial security reducing your
short-term liquidity in order to
increase your wealth over the long term
goal seeking emerges directly from a
long-term drive to increase future
freedom of action finally Richard
Fineman famous physicist once wrote that
if human civilization were destroyed and
you could pass only a single concept on
to our descendants to help them rebuild
civilization that concept should be that
all matter around us is made out of tiny
elements that attract each other when
they're far apart but repel each other
when there
close together my equivalent of that
statement to pass on to descendants to
help them build artificial intelligences
or to help them understand human
intelligence is the following
intelligence should be viewed as a
physical process that tries to maximize
future freedom of action and avoid
constraints in its own future thank you
very much
[Applause]